وصلت عزيزات امنيه مشدده ومع رفض والي
العاصمه السماح بالتظاهر جبهه الخلاص
الوطني المعارضه في تونس تنظم مسيره
احتجاجيه للتنديد بحمله الاعتقالات التي
استهدفت رموزها
لتصل الى شارع الحبيب بورقيبه حيث تجمع
المحتاجون وعائلات نشطاء المعتقلين
للمطالبه باطلاق سراحهم
اولا النقطه الاولى اللي احنا نطالبو انهم
يسيبوا المساجين السياسيين اللي ما عندهم
حتى تهمه هذه الحاجه الاولى والحاجه
الثانيه نحب نقولو اللي احنا المسار
الديمقراطي
ميسي دخلنا في منعرج خايب برشا مانيش
مسلمين فيه
ياتي هذا التحرك مع زياده حده الازمه
السياسيه في البلاد بين الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد ومعارضيه عقب حمله اعتقالات
واسعه
اعتقالات سعيد انها تاتي في اطار قضيه
التامر على امن الدوله
[تصفيق]
بينما ترى المعارضه انها تهدف الى التغطيه
على الفشل في معالجه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه
هذا النظام
قاعد يغطي في الفشل بتاعه جمله واضحه يغطي
في الفشل نتاعو في كل المجالات
بهالمسرحيات السيئه الاخراج من اعتقالات
رغم صديقي
في الشارع بينما تراوح لازمه سياسيه
مكانها رغم دعوات الحوار والتهدئه التي لم
تلقى حتى الان اذان صاغيه بل باتت
لايقافات والمحاكمات فصلا اخر من فصول
المشهد السياسي التونسي المعقد
مع تصاعدي الازمه تصدر جمعيه القضاه
التونسيين بيانا يصف تصريحات الرئيس
المتكرره تجاه القضاه بالخطيره
ويعتبرها تدخل المباشرا في سير التحقيقات
التي يجريها القضاء مع الموقوفين ونظر
لتساعد دائره الاعتقالات التي استهدفت
سياسيين ومحامينا ونقابيين واعلاميين فان
تشكيل جبهه موحده مناهضه للرئيس بات قريبا
وفق ما يرى البعض مشاكل خلقها قيس سعيد
وهي يعني حركت الشارع من جديد ضده ووحدت
المعارضه حتى ولو بطريقه تلقائيه ولا تريد
هذه المعارضه التوحد طيله سنه ونصف لكن
اليوم هي توحدت يعني بفضل قيس سعيد
انا اوان محاسبه اعداء الشعب جمله لطالما
كررها الرئيس قيس سعيد الذي دعا مرارا
وتكرارا القضاه التونسيين الى تطبيق
القانون على الجميع وعلى قدم المساواه
وانه لا تراجع عن النصر في معركه التحرير
الوطنيه على حد وصفه
الجزيره تونس